it is april 7th 2022 and you're watching
the code report machine intelligence is
the last invention humanity will ever
need to make ai has already made many
jobs obsolete and is well on its way to
replacing pilots doctors soldiers and of
course us programmers one of the last
bastions of humanity is art or so we
thought as of yesterday digital artists
and designers have been put on notice
openai the team behind gpt-3 just
announced daley to a neural network that
can turn natural language into images
and it's some of the wildest technology
you've ever seen imagine i gave you a
requirement to draw something ridiculous
like a bowl of soup that looks like a
monster spray painted on a wall daley
can create realistic novel images that
have never been seen before from a
simple text prompt like that if we tweak
the request a little bit asking it to
look like plasticine we get totally
different results we can ask it for
pencil drawings styles inspired by
famous artists photorealistic renderings
and really anything you can imagine
because the ai is built on top of 40 000
years of human artwork going all the way
back to cave drawings this tool is not
open to the public yet but the open ai
team was nice enough to generate a ship
sailing through a sea of fire for me in
addition to unique image generation it
can also replace things in existing
images like when you need to insert your
ex-girlfriend into an instagram photo it
can also take an image as an input then
create a bunch of different variations
with different styles and angles pretty
terrifying i mean awesome but how does
this thing actually work well it's based
on gpt3 the same model that powers
things like github copilot for writing
code it's trained on a massive
collection of images with labeled text
descriptions most importantly it
understands how different objects in an
image relate to each other like how a
panda relates to a skateboard relates to
santa monica there's a paper titled
hierarchical text conditional image
generation with clip latency if you want
to get into the finer details but
basically it's a decoder or transformer
that uses a process called diffusion
which starts with a pattern of random
pixels that are gradually moved around
until they satisfy the text input to
make high quality images it generates
512 different possible outcomes then
uses a neural network called clip to
predict human aesthetic judgments by
ranking the results and rejecting the
ones that don't look good pretty amazing
and it feels like one step closer to
artificial general intelligence but what
does a tool like this mean for the world
here are my initial thoughts this could
put a big dent into businesses like
istock and shutterstock if everybody can
just create their own original stock
photography photoshop as a tool might
become way less important because this
is essentially an automatic photoshop
now when it comes to nfts which are
already oversaturated someone could
instantly flood the market with tons of
unique art how about website and logo
design you can just pick your favorite
website or logo then generate a million
different unique variations
realistically though it's not going to
replace designers anytime soon in fact
it should be a very useful tool for them
like copilot is for programmers the big
question though is what does it mean for
memes i think memes will be safe for the
time being i can also imagine a lot of
potential for abuse with a tool like
this by creating explicit or offensive
content now i have to be real with you
guys this report is very troubling for
me personally because the writing is on
the wall agi is not far away now that
machines can clone voices write code and
make art it has all the skills to take
my job damn it i need your clothes your
boots and your motorcycle this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one maybe